okay just tell us kai do me a favor get
a get my uh
uh handle on twitter twitter
so okay let me see i'll actually do it
let me
we are live okay perfect well we're live
by the way
we're live with the guy giving 50 bucks
in the whatever currency
mindfulattraction.org and says hey pat
bet david you're next
watch out he's referencing a lebron
james
tweet that maybe we'll talk about today
ricky it's good to have you
we got rick i'm excited thank you
i think it's a very important
observation the viewers have to make in
today
obviously we have batman here we have
joker here we have kind of back we have
a tequila here
of uh the rock he tried it two days ago
i still haven't tried it adam still
hasn't tried it when we get to 35 000.
we'll do a shot when we get to four
we'll do shots who knows every 500 about
3 500 will do a shot hopefully we'll
get about 4 000 and we'll turn it off 5
000 will get turned
but there's a couple other things in the
props here you don't see and that is
adam's shirts now
oh yeah we did it it's not buttoned up
he's
representing yeah
i'm surprised my shirt is lower than
yours bro i'm wearing a v-neck today
what's up with that you know i had to
change it up bro i'm gonna keep guys
guessing
that thick gold chain though bro i gotta
i gotta i got a very thin
chain with a miami heat logo and a
jewish star i'm working my way up
to the thick gold chain you're iced out
you're black yes sir today well i i
this is actually something that i wear
all the time it's a centenario
which is uh it represents the 100 year
university uh anniversary of mexico's
existence
so they make them every 100 years and
they haven't made one recently it's kind
of a it's kind of a status symbol within
the mexican community as well well
you've got status we all know that no i
don't got studies oh yeah
i think so a lot of them does not have
satisfaction not a lot of people have a
song made after them he
literally has a song made after by by
pretty famous artists by the way can we
hear it
in the mexican community and tells his
story
yeah that you know michoacan he comes i
had had somebody translated for me two
weeks ago to hear what he's saying
it's actually all about our frontier
ricky straight up straight up yes
it's got a music video oh yeah i don't
know if we can play the music video
how can we not play the song that is
about ricky shout out to my boyfriend
uh my boy alex he did an incredible job
with it uh
we filmed it in harupa valley the music
video was sick
they're great artists he's from me
trucking as well immigrant living the
american dream with his family so i'm
very proud of him him and legal
crew they're just great people to work
with and super humble so listen can we
get a little sample even if you have to
sing it what's up
yeah i'm about to sing your own come on
you're a performer you got to see it
though you got to see
me see it to you but if you've got any
questions that you want us to talk about
any topics
i put the link below of my twitter
account go up there
uh comment send your tweet with
hashtag uh pbd podcast for us to comment
on kai can you do me a favor somebody
uh deleted my comment and i'm
valuetainment i think it's mario or
somebody back there thinking it's a fake
profile
it was actually me putting it because
god forbid you're next you know mario's
jump in front of that bullet
you know mario's jumping in front of
that book well listen gangster we got a
lot of things to cover today we got a
lot of things to cover today uh netflix
looks like they got competition they're
a little worried about disney passing
them up
world soccer was turned on its head by
the creation collapse of the european
super league and a chaotic and shocking
48-hour period
which we'll find out who has power in
europe the billionaires
the leagues the players or the fans
we're gonna find that because this
reveals a lot
youtube rival seems tremendous growth to
welcoming users on the left or the right
rumble ceo says
uh elon musk's proclaims himself
as the emperor of mars which kind of
validates
what you are saying it all along man
elon musk also said that he was a secret
service special agent when he donated to
the republican party and fec
filing shows he is this is not a
spoof right kai this is a real story
that you got here that he says he was a
secret service agent
for a special agent for republicans very
interesting tom brady says actions speak
louder than wars to pat my homes
they went back and forth and pat mahomes
said we'll find out in 20 years who is
better i love the fact that he has the
audacity
to say that but i also love the fact
that tom brady is finally calling
out everyone saying he's the greatest of
all time
vanessa bryan nike opt out to renew 20
year long
long-term relationship uh partnership
over differences so nike
said no to extending the contract with
kobe bryant on the shoes
i really want to dig into that one venmo
just added crypto
trading as personal finance apps look to
cash in on the latest surgeon to
digital currency billionaire linkedin
founder
reed hoffman tells businesses to stop
funding politicians who support voting
rights restrictions let's define
voting rights restrictions lululemon
launching a resale program
taking back uh like new clothing meaning
so if the clothes are new they're taking
it back and then they're reselling it
should democrats pack the supreme court
maybe we'll get into that and obviously
everything that happened with derek
chovin the last 24 hours
which has caused mayhem and as well as
the shooting that took place with the
knife the
the teenagers we'll show the video kai
if you have the right video for us to
show we have any kind of video to show
be good to at least
give a glimpse of what happened there
and then we'll get into that topic
ohio police kills a black teenage girl
seen threatening others
with knife senator bernie sanders
introduces bill to make college free and
have wall street pay for it
waters demons waters to demonstrate get
more confrontation on maxine
waters bernie sanders and aoc get two
percent each in 2024 iowa
democratic caucus poll without biden
aoc is getting two percent let me say
this one more time
aoc is already being looked at as a
potential
future president ricky think about aoc
as
your president ricky's president
future president yeah latino you would
still care
i don't support mexico no no i don't
support this whole she looks like me
he looks like me so uh uh hitler looked
like the jews too
no he did i don't know no no i'm just
saying just because they look like you
doesn't
salinas de cordatin which was a
president of mexico which literally
bankrupted mexico he looked like me too
yeah i don't care all right i don't buy
you that's a bunch of bf's
maybe that's tricky we got a lot of 40
guns we can't have that we can't
make that our first story los angeles
come in uh could offer thousands uh
of poor residents thousand dollars a
month no questions asked that to mayor
garcetti story
putin warns west of harsh response if it
crosses russia's red lines
dozens of alexi navalny supporters
arrested on day of protesters against
vladimir putin alexei and navalny we
haven't covered the story yet i think we
ought to cover this story
i agree uh we'll get into that senator
elizabeth warren
wants to grill the billionaire who said
the rich would hide their assets from a
wealth
tax we're definitely going to cover that
and uh
adam's best friend donald trump very
seriously considering 2024 run
misses helping people okay so
before we get started before we get into
the topics i got to address
maybe what people are thinking what's
that well we talked about you know me
you know you know
suited and booted you know iced out pbd
what's that you've had a three-day run
of just looking fresh looking sharp you
even posted a picture on instagram
i called you swaggy p i think you could
take that name
i feel good this week by the way shout
out to this kid yesterday sam and i went
to get a haircut this guy named drew
who's a celebrity uh
what do you call him barber celebrity
barber yeah okay so
jennifer sends me i said baby i got to
get a haircut because you know rapper
tony i haven't cut my hair for six weeks
because i don't trust anybody touching
my mind
barbara just uh i would rather tony to
come in and cut her and cut everyone's
hearing and go back home that's how much
we love rapper tony
but jennifer says this is where you got
to go get a haircut she sends me this
four weeks ago
two days ago drew sends a instagram
story tagging me saying last night i had
a dream i was cutting pat's hair so you
gotta be kidding me
so the same address jen sent so i get
the address i say where are you based
out of this place sam and i go in there
this guy's quoting videos from
five years ago six years he was
emotional crying for five
minutes it was the most incredible
experience with this guy so this haircut
is sponsored by true celebrity barber
in boca out of meisner if he's listening
so you look fresh
yeah you're posting fresh picks the hair
looks good plans we got big plans yeah
we're taking over the world that
i gotta i gotta address the what people
are talking about baby we gotta bring up
the fact that you posted another post
saying
i'm thinking about just shaving my head
going back to the show you're not with
it
hell no shake what your mama gave you
back we know that check what your mama
gives you okay so you got great hair
rocket
we're gonna see ricky on the other hand
he's going shaved head you know but you
know how easy it is to wake up in the
morning you don't have to do anything
with your hair it's a lot easier than
having to do this every morning
that's an easier life than this is a lie
but we'll see we'll see what's gonna
happen but you're the kind of guy that
likes a tough life and you like this you
know
15 minutes to get this hair in the
morning to talk to it to
woo it too you know it's so frustrating
yeah
sometimes okay are we ready with your
unbuttoned you know
shirt this is for ricky
last night we had the most epic debates
over sushi about flowers
about guns about religion about what's
more likely
to happen to adam is he more likely to
be a republican or a christian
and am i more likely to be a uh what was
it a
jew or a democrat which was a great
debate last night i know what the people
have yeah
let's see what they're gonna say about
it anyways okay listen if you just got
on if you haven't subscribed to the
channel do so
we're trying to get this thing to 100
000 subs to do it more than twice a week
if you're enjoying it
we're striving for that and to help with
the algorithm smash the thumbs up button
if you're happy that we have ricky back
on
here with us let's get right into it
let's talk about
the potential future presidential
candidate aoc
okay and bernie's al already been one
but aoc
page six if you want to go to it page
six if you want to go to
iowa caucuses 2024
uh bernie sanders and aoc get just two
percent each and 2024 iowa
democratic caucuses poll without biting
that's a newsweek
story okay so even though they're a
distant
long shot in a new survey of iowa
democratic national presidential
caucuses
that does not include president joe
biden the poll released monday by
republican firm victory insights
shows both progressive lawmakers with
two percent support each
vice president kamala harris is the
clear front runner at 28
with secretary of transportation pete
putich following at 15
and former first lady michelle obama at
12 percent undecided was the second
most popular choice overall at 16 with
five percent saying they would vote for
someone else biden was far and away
the top choice when he was including the
poll with 63 percent support
the poll would was conducted over the
phone among 600 iowa democrats
on april 8th thoughts
you know um
it just you know ignorance is bliss
that's for sure
uh to live in a world where people are
gonna feed into your victimhood
mentality
your the world's against me mentality um
it's an easy life to live because you
can just sit there and blame everybody
for your
for your uh for your uh misfortunes or
for your bad
your bad decision making uh and then
when you have somebody with
12.1 million views i mean um 12.1
million followers
um that can that can say yes you're
right you're a victim
uh and mak you know actually i'm not
surprised
i'm i'm i'm uh disappointed in people's
idiocy
but i'm not surprised that she's getting
that much that much clout because
uh most of america or not most i'm sorry
let me retract that
a lot of americans are self-pity type of
people
they believe in uh uh institutional
racism they believe that the there's a
government out to get them which i don't
believe any of that [ __ ] i just
don't
just you know uh maybe it's because i've
lived through it
you know i'm a hispanic immigrant for me
truck at mexico i actually come from one
of the most
cartel war-torn parts of mexico and uh i
dropped out of high school
i was incarcerated 13 years ago and here
i am sitting in front of you
uh and nobody gave me anything we were
never on government assistance my mom
was a single mom taking care of two kids
she took care of me alejandro
uh working two jobs she sold tequila and
she was doing
and she was a waitress never my mom
didn't know what government assistant
was
so therefore we survived that and here i
am
uh as a top one percent income earner of
america with no help from the government
ever so i just don't i can't
it's very hard for me for me to buy in
well you know a lot of people i
understand if you're you know second
generation wealth how you can say well
you were born in some money i get that
but we were not born into money meaning
thanks to your help and your coaching so
what i'm getting at is that
if you put yourself in the right
environment and put yourself around the
right people
that you're gonna win i just but a lot
of people are gonna buy into there's no
opportunities if you can't find
opportunities in america where the hell
else are you going to find them you're
screwed
this is this is people come here migrate
here if i'm almost taking the number was
91 more
91 million people come here a year
either passing through or staying here
they're coming here i mean if people are
trying to are dying on the way up from
from the south of the border to get here
there's a reason why they're doing that
nobody's migrating to china nobody's
migrating to germany nobody's mine
they're migrating here
so if you can't as an american find an
opportunity in america
what the hell are you gonna do with your
life we are the beacon of capitalism
free enterprise and entrepreneurship and
if you can't do it here
you're screwed and i'm glad that you
know elon musk is
calling himself the emperor of mars
because that's the only other place you
can go
well i mean you can't do it here where
the hell else are you gonna do it well
i mean oh my god you need to go to
another place so maybe let me ask you a
different question by the way uh aoc is
born october 13th
i'm very surprised she's a libra because
we're five days apart she's 13 i'm 18
right but she's born october 13th
1989 she is 31 years old
four years from now she'll be 35 years
old that's the age to be able to be
a president the way they're doing the
math apparently if she is
in this poll that means she is eligible
to run if she chose to
but this is more important more
importantly i think the question
let's say okay let's run a poll let's
run a poll let's run a po i'm actually
curious with everybody here that's
watching this
let's run a poll okay how likely is it
that in the next 40 years aoc who's only
31 today in the next 40 years she's 71.
how many elections does she have in the
next four years 10 shots 10 shots okay
well if it's a two-term you know that
other stuff fine but let's just say
she's got 10 shots
right what is the likelihood of aoc in
the next
40 years to be the president of united
states next 40 years
likelihood of winning
give me a percentage i i i'm kind of i'm
kind of spit on the negative whitepap
because
i think that we're going in such a in
such a bad direction right now under the
leadership that we have right now and
it's just obvious this is not an opinion
it's
mathematical facts that we're pushing so
hard that we're realizing
i think americans some american majority
americans are realizing elon musk are
the best
the left are losing the middle right so
i think we're pushing so hard on one
side
the left is losing the middle losing the
middle elon must quoted that he's
clearly he
tweeted that so i think that there's two
parts to it
if if they don't push hard enough
there's a maybe 80
chance but if they push too hard people
are gonna realize that
we're under really bad leadership like i
don't think they realize that right now
right
so once once they realize that we're
losing all battles at the border with
with um
global trade yeah with the economy with
the stock i mean we're losing every
battle right america's losing every
battle
and you don't have to agree with it look
at the numbers if you don't agree
because you don't look at the numbers
uh if they push hard enough i think
people are going to wake up and we're
going to rebound from this on a hard way
on the other side
um so but if if they still people are
still not even dumb and they're not
realizing how bad they're being affected
then yeah there's 80 percent chance
she'll be president next 40 years
unfortunately give me a percentage five
percent no i.e i
wow you sold me on the idea that victims
are the best recruiters
hands down you started my friends four
years ago yep you said victims are the
best recruiters yep
and i'm like you're right so i think
that she's gonna be 80 percent
unbelievable what do you think yeah well
shout out to ricky he's passionate he's
fired
up he's um he's really going in i don't
think he's a fan of aoc i don't know if
you can tell that so
80 80 i think is aggressive bro
um i'm thinking nobody thought trump was
gonna be president look at that
look let's talk about track record here
she might not even be 35 by the time the
election comes up so i think it's just
before i get into my 40 years in the
next 40 years yeah yeah but let me just
okay well let me just you know you you
you went on a diet tribe here let me
give my diatribe and then
we go okay and then i'll go look she
hasn't done [ __ ] in her career
okay she's a representative when's the
last time a senator other than barack
obama has been elected
president okay kennedy i don't know who
else so a representative she's big in
new york people in new york like her
that's great
you got to win something bigger than
your district to actually become
president so
look we're talking four years away and
she might not even be eligible
to even run at that point i think we're
way ahead of schedule we're even
talking about her uh let's get through
let's get through the midterms yeah i
don't think she's
how do you think i don't think she's
anywhere near qualified whatsoever
hey player let me talk here bro i'll put
down another button bro
i'll go down another [ __ ] button but
that doesn't make sense what you're
saying though
i don't think she's qualified to even
consider running whatsoever and i don't
think she's going
to one trip one person and the other one
wasn't even a senator listen
we've already seen that happen
all right all right go ahead so um
you're fascinated to hear from you too
exactly listen it's way too early to
even suggest she's pulling at two
percent let's
she's fun she gets the you know like you
still have an absolute question the
likelihood that she would become
president yeah person i'll give her 10
that's high by the way just so you know
just the fact that you're saying 10
i'm high at 10 ricardo's throwing 80.
and he's reasonable
what i'm saying to you was just the fact
that you think
in the next 40 40 years i get that what
i'm trying to tell you is it's a real
conversation
that's what i'm saying like yeah it is
real yeah you understand it is that name
okay so now let me give you the
follow-up question that's the that's
where i've been trying to get into
for this entire time today is 2046
2046. okay today's 2046.
your president is aoc what does america
look like
go there by the way 2046 is 25 years
from now
she is only 56 years old what does
america look like well
let me just let's establish what her
life looks like okay first before we can
go to america number one she's single
she's a waitress she hasn't made any
money
she hasn't done anything in her career
25 years okay exactly so
at that point yeah she would
presumably be married have some kids
um potentially her outlook on life would
change not everything is stagnant things
change
she might develop her views the world
might be a different place
so give people a little credit to the
fact that their
perspectives might change you weren't
always a capitalist
you weren't always anti-a democrat you
were re
reasonable at some point i presume i'm
not reasonable now
no i i'd say more you're literally let
me have a little question let me ask the
question is the
the argument of socialism reasonable i
don't i don't
is the argument on socialism is the
argument reasonable or is the concept
reasonable
whatever any argument is reasonable no
no having a having a debate is real as a
person
to establish what the fact is a person
who believes in
like i can see a democrat switching to
independent like john stosso went from
hey i'm the guy that's exposing all
these businesses finally one day i'm
like what the hell am i doing i'm
helping consumer affairs
more than i am small business owners and
i'm making fun of these guys and they're
losing their businesses
there's no way i'm going to do this i
want to be a libertarian he flips but he
went from a
center left john f kennedy type of a
democrat to what a libertarian he didn't
flip to be a
republican right what is the likelihood
of
aoc changing that much philosophically
the next 24 years well i'll tell you if
she has any chances of
to answer your question specifically
becoming the president for the masses
she better flip and fight i i don't
think you're i don't she's not gonna win
being that far left
wait wait she's not wait she's not gonna
win being that far left
correct okay i have a whole different
view on this but ricky i want to go to
you you still haven't answered my
question for me
i asked you if 20
45 aoc is the pres 2046 aoc's the
president
she's 55 56 years old what does america
look like i'll tell you we'll have a lot
of flipping debt more than
whatever we have now what else will
america look like no as far as they're
going to come after ricky's 40 guns
but but first of all before i continue
to say are you picking up ricky's audio
i want to make sure that mike is picking
up his own
so so to be to be to be to be
showing your point real quick and then
i'll go to pbd's question
no she's not going to change maxine
waters hasn't changed nancy pelosi
hasn't changed
bernie sanders hasn't changed these
people have not changed they don't these
people don't change because they have to
follow a narrative
okay that's the only way they could win
the votes because they have to follow
the narrative even
by the way she said that at the border
the crisis that we have at the border
right now even though it's worse than
when we had it with trump
she said that it had to do with climate
change
that's literally what she said so she
has to she's going to continue with
their narrative because that's only what
she's going to continue to get voted in
she needs to vote the the the victims
need to keep only hearing but
what do we look like as a country you
have a you have aoc as a president
we're definitely going to have our
debt's going to be through what you said
adam
uh def definitely will not have any guns
definitely wouldn't have any guns uh
she's gonna run out all the capitalists
and all the business owners out of the
country
they'll end up in another country uh and
uh in the com the company
we're gonna go into it we'll be uh she
stays around long enough these ideas
stay wrong long enough and by the way
it's anybody if you're listening to this
and you think this cannot happen to
america you are naive
the world has said has said seven world
powers pat
america is a seventh world power so rome
fell
and there was a one point that there was
there was a satan that said that the sun
never set on the roman empire
rome fell babylon fell great britain
fell all these countries have fought
every what goes up must come down so to
believe and sit here and listen to us
and say oh that'll never happen here you
are
literally naive you did not pay
attention history guys have never picked
up a history book
but yeah would be we'd be destroyed as a
country and there would be another
america somewhere else because would we
though so so let's go there
let's go there and let's go there and
say she and if she wins she's not going
to be a one-term president she'll be a
two-term
she'll be two-term two-term because okay
let's but let's speculate this is all
purely speculation
what happens afterwards so do so does it
push
back so far that do we go back to being
far right
what is america after aoc can you
recover even if you go faster
i don't know if you could like let's
look at history since and i think that's
a great point you made about the
empires of civilization every every
eight years the pendulum swings it's a
reason why you go from a reagan to a
bush
to a clinton and you go from a clinton
to a bush and you go from a bush to a
obama and you go from obama to a trump
and a trump to a biden
it's the same old narrative that we've
had even before reagan you had a jimmy
carter and you had a gerald ford
and you had a nixon and you had an lbj
it's the same old theme
and every four years every eight years
that's why a president runs on
change change barack obama ran on change
trump ran on change
biden ran on they got to get that
[ __ ] this uh the orange monster out
of here we gotta change things
every eight years people run on change
it's the most common theme
ever when it comes to elections so god
forbid an aoc becomes into power
you know somebody who's that ricky
wholeheartedly believes in
will come in and the whole country will
rally around them and say
all right we've had
what happened can you just turn me up a
little bit let me ask you a different
question here's a different question for
you here's a different question for you
you ever been robbed at gunpoint right
no no
have you yes okay i had a gun pointed at
me not rob but yeah
you had a gun okay i've had a gun
pointed at me yeah okay
okay so all three of us now do you think
what's the likelihood of you having uh
somebody robbing you at gunpoint
it's like a likelihood between now and
the day you die for ricky no no foreign
to be a lot higher than me
between now and your end of days what's
the likelihood of that happening is my
shirt open or no
give me any percentage one percent one
percent okay fair enough okay
uh what's the likelihood of
uh you getting into a terrible car
accident
twenty-five percent you i don't think so
maybe no i think it's
it's my uber driver's drunk person yeah
it's one percent two percent
what's the two percent what's the
likelihood of
a uh empire fallen america
fallen what's the likelihood of an
empire falling
pretty damn high yeah really i'm asking
you
what do you think twenty percent okay
you say what
i'd say at least forty to fifty percent
okay i think it's inevitable it's just a
matter of is it a hundred years from now
five hundred years from a thousand
i think it's gonna i think it's a
hundred percent if you ask me yes
because the five billion in
infinity i think it's just it's
eventually gonna fall right so what
is really the responsibilities of the
citizen of that era
of that era what is our responsibility
the responsibility of the citizens of
our era
today 2021 is to make sure this
generation is not the one that falls
right neither next or the following
because we have what kids
grandkids so our job is to keep that
going for
two more generations it's why we have to
care about it now
what causes an empire to fall what
causes a great empire to fall what
typically happens
what are symptoms of a great empire
fallen well
a thinking that you can't fall that's
exactly what he was saying
okay so you're being too naive to think
that'll never happen
what else well i mean historically his
story if you look at history it's it's
it's been uh uh uh um
uh uh i'm sorry world power's been
overturned because of dictatorship
so dictatorship to me is giving too much
trust into one person one person
leadership i'm writing this down so
number one is naivete
i even say number two would be to uh
overthrowing a dictator
right kinda like what they did in uh
iran right they threw over through
and by the way what they tried to do
with the dog by the way fidel castro
just said
fidel castro's brother just stepped down
yeah uh but look
the replacement is still accomplished
uh and then also to me would be uh would
be definitely socialism
because communism will come in the form
of socialism so so rather than saying
socialism or communism what does that
mean
is it is it all the wealth you're weak
and the empire
created they start overspending the
world is that is that because that's
historically that's what's happening so
you overspend
like what happens a uh uh you know a
billionaire family dies a rich family
does the money goes to who
the inheritance goes to the kids and the
kids never earned the money what do they
do
we are essentially experiencing a bit of
that with american men from the richest
country in the world to now with the
most debt
no one has more debt than we have let's
just face it we also have the highest
gdp
to potentially reverse course yeah but
we we have
we have today to if you really break
down
the unpaid commitment to social security
medicare our national debt 24 trillion
our debt is 50 time no let me put it
25 times to 30 times more than our gdp
okay
so that means you make forty thousand
dollars a year you have 1.2 million
dollars in credit card debt
that's america today if you want to put
that in perspective let me say that one
more time
america is making 40 grand a year and it
has a 1.2 million dollar
credit card you're saying crime funded
liabilities future liabilities
24 trillion dollars you're not talking
about
social security is versus the actual
debt i think that's like 100
even if you know it's not a hundred
percent gdp is what 20 trillion what are
you talking about
17 trillion no what's the gdp of united
states oh my gosh can you pull up gdp of
u.s
gdp of u.s is uh uh uh
you're thinking a different number
you're not thinking gdp of us 20
trillion
okay so say 20 trillion dollars i just
did wait say gdp is 20 trillion dollars
and what's our debt go to five trillion
trillion
go to on go to uh collective unpaid debt
oh that's the u.s that's how you
calculate your debt
fair enough that's what i was asking you
to clarify yeah if you calculated we're
talking about what we owe in social
security what we owe in medicaid
we are total unpaid right there on the
website
go to the debt clock that we have go to
debt clock
it's probably at 27 trillion okay let me
show this to you
28 trillion national debt is 28.
overnight we we
we lost another national debt is 28 but
there's a number of total debt that we
have it's in 1200
unfunded u.s liabilities is what 162
trillion dollars okay that's a lot of
money we have to pay that money right
let me let me explain
over time though that's not i'm not
saying that's not but you you have to
pay that
correct you have to pay that can a 40
year person afford a 400 000 credit card
no
no okay do you understand like how
pathetic that i'm right there that's a
scary
right there okay yeah all right so so
number three is what
overspending the amount of money that
you've earned right or the generation
before you yes has earned so how do you
want to award that you want to put a
lack of
fiscal responsibility well why don't we
pull up what
we discussed the other day with the
based on the world economic
economic forum stats that united states
was doing pretty good i think we were
number 17 in the world or whatever the
as far as economic freedom we did this
that's economic freedom okay economic
freedom we're talking the one thing that
we sucked at
32 percent
number one naivete number two is too
much trust into
one person number three is what lack of
fiscal
responsibility right what else is it war
okay what kind of war yeah
any kind of war nuclear war bio are
fallen
fine let's put a war traditionally it
wasn't sure earlier what else we put
that's war what else you want to put
what else is another reason why this
happens
okay invasion you want to put invasion
i have i have one i want to put in but
let me see what he's going to say huh
i think it's kind of part of four but
let's put laziness sluggard
right what i would add what i would add
to it
is a spirit of division within the
nation
or a spirit of division within the
nation what else is now
exactly yeah what else is it i think a
level of
comfort and not willing to seek pain or
not willingness it's kind of lazy it's
the same thing
so can we also put a lack of education
in
uh people are being overly entertained
and how do you define that more
entertainment than education
so let's put entertainment over
education and then the other one i was
going to say
is our morals drop we morally lose our
values and principles because
right look even even something as basic
as save your money right they say that's
a very
morally values and principle
conservative philosophy saving money
right so what what's the eighth one
values and principles down the drain
right yes
we don't really care anymore what you're
doing oh go ahead it's okay i'll go
ahead it's okay oh it's okay that's okay
so everything's all it's okay right how
much of this is happening today in
america
uh naivete where are we at with that oh
oh my god
ridiculous too much trust in one person
yes okay
already happening uh how about that's
been happening
lack of lack of lack of fiscal i
actually don't think we're fully there
where
no too much trust in one person i don't
think people trust buying i don't even
think
uh democrats trust biden no so we're not
there for trump
it was trump and obama they're very
similar because there was a lot of trust
in obama there was a lot of trust in a
trump from the right there was zero
trust in
trump from the left zero right so we've
not gotten collection
we're not there yet collectively were we
given one person too much
the good news with america is no one man
has had too much power in america yeah
that's a very big benefit we have to
understand that's the insurance policy
look at
look at your friend vladimir putin he's
got i mean he's got a lot of trust in
him bro that's exactly what we're going
through
lack of fiscal responsibility i think
that's a check because we don't have any
of it today
fully agree so so far i got two of them
war we don't have it right now
okay yeah so five lazy we have that
right now we can't say we don't have
that right now everything
in addition to that i would say fat and
lazy i put fat people are dying from
covid
because not because they're 87 were fat
some ridiculous percentage came back up
yeah okay
so six is uh a spirit of division
i'm gonna put a check 100 we're
absolutely divided today if you think
about uh
not here on the pbd podcast though we
can easily have any kind of this we're
here
we'll still go have a shot at you know
we'll have good dinner afterwards yeah
okay entertainment over education are we
consuming more entertainment
yeah how about the last one is we've
lost our values and principles
has that happened yet it's it's we're
not looking in the right direction yeah
i don't think we're there we're not
there yet
but we're very much in that direction so
then we're going to speed training so
then we got two here
values and principles and no one man has
had too much power and i gotta add
war as well those three so so the reason
why i'm talking about this is sometimes
adam
we're in the life insurance business
okay let's face it's not the sexiest
business when you tell somebody you're
an interesting
makes it sexy though baby that's good
ricky and erica but when you think about
it's not the sexiest business matter if
it gets a lot of shots taken at it right
you get
real estate is sexy oh my gosh keys
house oh
such a sexy business to be a part of
life is like oh my gosh babe close the
door don't answer the phone he just
wants to sell us a life insurance policy
great until people realize
there's scientific research shown that
100 of people die
okay this is true market research of
thousands of years that 100
of people died except for enoch and i
think one other person was taken
everybody else has been enoch you know
it's a biblical
reference here but so 100 of people die
now when it comes down to life insurance
get some people out with life insurance
oh my gosh give me a flipping break
yeah and then i'm so glad i bought it i
didn't think this was happening
i'm not telling you you know the empire
is going to fall all i'm saying is
we need an insurance policy against it
and the level of arrogance to not have
it
is what causes a lot of these great
empires to fall
right and today if we go into the
if you guys want to go into the shelving
case next we can go into what happened
yesterday derek shoving
because these two kind of yes concern me
the most
we just covered aoc now let's go to
shelvin if you want to go to page five
to talk about what happened with uh uh
uh chauvin okay so page five
former minneapolis police officer derek
schuman found guilty of murder
manslaughter and george floyd's death
business insider story okay
he was found guilty of second-degree
murder third-degree murder and
manslaughter in the death of george
floyd floyd died on may 25th after
chauvin
a minneapolis police officer at the time
knelt on his neck for
nine minutes eight minutes and 46
seconds to be exact during an arrest
chauvin faces up to 40 years in prison
for second degree murder
25 years for third degree and 10 years
for second degree manslaughter because
of chauvin
because chauvin was convinced and
convicted of all the charges he will be
sentenced
on the top charge of second degree
murder jurors
deliberate deliberated for a total of
nine hours
and 45 minutes before the court
announced they had a
verdict okay then tucker carlson's
reaction to derek shawn's
conviction was to cast doubt on jurors
who decided to murder
him heard murder george floyd after the
conclusion of derek chovan
murder trial tucker carlson's reaction
tuesday night was a question
the jury's motivation in reaching its
guilty verdict a few hours earlier
a jury of five men and seven women
returned to unanimous guilty verdict on
all three counts
against chauvin in the death of george
floyd carson carlson
characterized the verdict not as
impartial decision based on trial but
rather the jurors
way of saying please don't hurt us it
was part of a longer opening monologue
suggesting that the jurors were spurred
by fear of writing by people who have
been angered
by a verdict of not guilty can we trust
the way this decision was made he asked
so
having said that what are your thoughts
on what took place the last 24 hours
adam i'll go to you first and i'll come
to
ricky well i think um
i agree with this decision let's just
start with the the the basics here
i think um the guy
chauvin put his knee on george floyd's
neck and murdered the man
people want to say well he had drugs in
his system or well you know he wasn't a
great father that's not a reason to
[ __ ] to die
okay so anyone who has two eyeballs and
a brain and a heart will realize
yeah chauvin definitely played a part
now if you're part of the
chauvin's defense or if you want to be
the tucker carlson and you want to kind
of play both sides you can say
well how much of a cause was it was it
definitely
but i'm just gonna side with the jury
here and say yes guilty homie go to jail
um but bigger bigger than than this
is i think something that the democrats
did
uh in the election in 2020 was coin the
phrase defund the police i personally
think that's not a smart move
i think we need more police or better
trained police
i think the slogan should be de-escalate
the police not defund the police
de-escalate the police because everyone
who has an interaction with the police
these days especially black people that
[ __ ] gets escalated so quick
even yesterday uh a girl i don't know
what happened with that we could talk
about that
as well yeah but like why is everything
with the police
you know kill or be killed and kneeling
on the neck and killing the guy
or shooting person or someone's running
away you shoot him in the back
police i think there was a lady on bill
maher she was a journalist who actually
in her 40s became a police officer
and had to go through the training and
basically
commented on what police have to deal
with she said they're asked to do too
much
she said they're asked to be social
workers they're asked to be medics
they're act to be they're asked to be
heroes and warriors
and negotiators and everything they're
doing that and
all at the you know ripe age of 25 years
old either any of those jobs
is very hard to do any of those jobs to
do whether you're a nurse an emt a
negotiator social worker
now you're going to throw on top of that
a badge and a gun for someone who's
fresh out of you know not college but
college age they're asked to do too much
so
you throw a badge and a gun on them and
they get on a power trip we've all dealt
with police who's
been on a power trip so i think
look george floyd at the end of the day
was a martyr he was a symbol he was a
lightning rod he wasn't a hero
okay he he was a guy who had some issues
in his life
that happened to be at the wrong place
at the wrong time and had a knee on his
neck
and it went viral because everybody's
got a phone in their hands these days
and people are saying bro you're killing
him he's shouting out i can't breathe
he's calling for his mother anyone who
watched that
you'd have no heart to not sympathize
with what he was going through whether
he was on drugs or not
so you know what what carlson is also
looking to do because he brought up
tucker carlson he's basically saying
that
whether you like this or not derek
shovin was also a martyr
now why was he a martyr because let's
say just for a second hypothetically
that he actually
didn't kill george floyd let's just say
that for a second let's just say for
whatever reason
he didn't really kill him and have his
knee on his neck
he's a martyr because do you know what
would have happened in this country
if he was actually found innocent of all
charges
burn this [ __ ] to the ground
okay how bad you think it would have
been
better than you think like way worse
every major
rodney king rodney king was in la in one
city this is a national thing think
about it in the middle of a freaking
pandemic
yeah everyone in the country you know
blm
i get it you know people basically said
this is more important this is a reason
for me to leave my house
take off my freaking mask and get out
there and riot and and i would you know
they say you know
99 of the people the riots are uh
marching or was was peaceful i get it
the protest i get it
there were definitely some disgusting
looting and stuff that like that's going
on so
in my opinion george floyd was not a
hero but he is a symbol of
um accountability and
derek chovin also is a martyr whether
you like that or not but
um i think my my final point here is
one thing for sure is de-escalate the
police they have way too much power
they're asked to do too much
and they're not supposed to be doing at
the end of the day they're they're
supposed to
um they're no one's above the law
including law enforcement officers
they're supposed to protect the peace
and a lot of times and i get that 90
percent of cops 99 of cops are good
but they have so it's so tough to be a
cop you say that the like how hard is it
to be a
job today so hard to be a cop right now
be anything but a cop today
but i don't think that's i think
that we can have a pause and reset
moment and the police
because police don't forget people on
trial at the trial
yeah also said yeah he murdered him
police said that
police said that so when you have police
kind of ratting on your own i think you
know that you did something wrong so
um ricky what are you thinking uh you
know pat i'm gonna be honest with you i
i'm a little bit
i'm a little bit uh i'm split on this um
i don't like to argue points just to
argue them
uh i don't like to be uh irrational i'm
very i'm a very logical person when it
comes onto things like this
here's here's a reality behind things
during
the okay
i grew up in the hood okay me and all of
my friends
have been arrested either once or
multiple times and we've had
interactions with cops
i'm gonna tell you a quick story i it's
two in the morning
i'm coming home from dinner shout out to
pamila which has been my childhood
friend of mine
and she works with us right now in in
within our within our team
and we're going home okay well she gets
pulled over i'm not even driving
she gets pulled over and they run her
name everything's good well the cop
asked me what's your name
keep in mind i'm 19 years old i already
had a record by this time actually i'm
yeah
19 or 20 years old they pull my name
another cop pulls up
right so he pulls my name goes back into
his car says wait here
another actually two more cops pull up
because my name was pulled
okay this was 13 14 years ago
then they said get out of the car and
there's three cops waiting you know
outside okay cool
where are you going where you coming
from you get out yeah i get out of the
car i said okay
so here's a reality behind things
whether we like to admit it or not
okay whenever they ran his name
they realized he's been in prison more
than once and he put a gun
to the stomach of a pregnant woman while
they were robbing
so whenever you run somebody's name
and you see what they're capable of your
natural instincts are to tighten up
and to be a little bit more aggressive
with the person because you know that
they are naturally aggressive
yeah i can't breathe yeah he cried for
his mom and that's horrible to listen to
as a human being
right and there's no way to excuse that
because at that point your your humanity
has to come out and say you know what
something's wrong here if this person's
you know crying out that much
you already got them in handcuffs maybe
chill a little bit okay maybe
you got him this you guys should get
this and say surrounded he doesn't have
a gun on him yeah he
you got him like chill if this guy's
crying out chill
but but on the other hand
they had a different angle which the
news never put out
where uh chavin what's his name chavin
chauvin had his had his knee on his back
and not on his neck
so we're looking at a viewpoint down
where he's looking at the camera where
we see a knee and we see the guy's back
but we don't see
specifically where his knee is at even
though it looks like it's on his neck
well the reason that they were thinking
of quitting him is because they actually
had his he had his knee
on his back not on his neck now we had
this discussion you're like
well we don't know that well we don't
know that he had it on his leg either
that's the truth now is it unfortunate
that he died
yes is it is there any way to excuse
that
no now that trauma had anything to do
with killing him here's a reality
you don't know that neither do i we do
know that he was high on fentanyl
i'm very familiar with drugs because i
grew up in a drug-infested neighborhood
which
my city is one of the capital cities for
the cartels in the united states
that's where they're stationed a lot of
them are at and that's where they
distribute from so we're very familiar
with i grew up around it
we sold it we bought it we used it
that's just the reality behind the
very transparent i know what happens to
your heart rate when you're on drugs
you're it's not meant for you to be in a
situation where you're where you're
where you could get even more your heart
rate goes even more up because you can
have a heart attack
i've had friends overdose i had there's
in my neighborhood
there was three brothers with all three
of them overdosed on cocaine not on
fentanyl
nobody was around them and by the way
that's one of people i got stories like
that for days
i have many of my close friends overdose
on cocaine which is nowhere near like
fentanyl
nowhere it's not even a quarter of it so
when you're putting they just they just
they just overdosed
right and so when you have fentanyl
which right now as a matter of fact when
they're cooking this stuff they put
gloves on pat
they put gloves on like the people that
are cooking it because it's that
dangerous
they literally wear suits you know uh
biohazard suits
when they're making it in mexico in the
in the in the in the
what are they called in the lab in the
lab okay
in the kitchen in the kitchen so when
you're consuming that [ __ ]
and to think that the most dangerous
drug in america
right now had nothing to do with this
death is simply insane
you're you're you're naive you do not
know how drugs work
if you could overdose on cocaine you can
overdose on meth
fentanyl is by far it's ten times worse
than both of those drugs combined
so to think that that didn't play a role
it's just ridiculous
now is it okay no do i i'm just split on
it i'm not going to take one set or the
other
anything could have happened anything
could happen do you trust the justice
system
no hell no no you don't trust the
justice system no no way so let me ask
you what do you trust more
politicians or the justice system uh
if i had to choose between both maybe
the justice system but not politicians
got it so
because let me tell you why though yeah
because if i have the money to hire a
lawyer yeah the lawyer's gonna get me
out of it okay
so i can't buy a you can buy a talked
about yesterday one of your lawyers in
australia who
you know he says every client of mine
they're all
criminals they're all you know all this
other stuff but if they got the money i
can uh
help them out right okay so you you
trust the justice system more than you
trust uh politicians yes on both sides
by the way okay
how much do you think how much do you
think these jurors
made the decision based on facts and
what happened and how much you think the
decision was based on
pat when the president is calling you
telling you we hope that you make the
right decision
and maxine waters is calling they don't
want to be the cause of riots all over
the country
the president wasn't calling the jurors
bro the jury i mean if you who call them
if you believe in impartial who calls
the jury and who calls them no nobody's
calling the germans
nobody asked the jurors to make the
right decision nobody did are you sure i
would hope not would you like to pull it
up
hold it up sure i don't know what you're
talking about i think it's calling all
right can we
have a go can you pull up where uh where
biden asked the george to make the right
decision uh are you serious you're
talking about a public speech bro what
are you talking about are you talking
about the public are you serious right
now
i can't believe that if you actually
show me a [ __ ] public speech right
now i'm going to get very
needs to be public for you did he call
he called up the jurors are you what are
you saying right now i didn't pray
brighton uh trades lightning in comments
lightly on comments come on
come on tread lightly there's no
lightning with biting you guys an idiot
bro
traveling trial is jury deliberates
president joe biden waited carefully
into a discussion about murder trial
ricky
hold on bro derrick chavin and dave
driving attorneys
right so he's talking about he's hoping
they give the right verdict
also when you say this publicly he's not
going to weigh on a juror that's a
nobody compared to the president of
america
which they know what roy
what do you think what do you think
about this yeah so but here's what i'm
here's what i'm asking but first of all
maxine waters said
what would her comments if if the trials
doesn't go the way it's supposed to be
we need to be
confrontational at the highest level
guards were shot that day yeah
to a confrontational so so here's here's
what's going on
do you want to be part of that pat do
you want to be part of the country
correct me if i'm wrong you're not
allowed to listen to the news you're not
allowed to be following this kind of
stuff that's kind of the whole part of
it you know
we've had a lot of people do fraud and
elections by the way i want everybody
listeners to realize i'm not speculating
that a phone call was made to anybody
i'm not speculating i know i've
interviewed a lot of mobsters
and the mobsters know how to get a hold
of the jurors okay if monsters know how
to get a hold of jurors i promise you
politicians are going to get ahold of
jurors so
if a sammy gravano knows how to get a
juror to help out god he never you know
other people can do the same but let's
set that aside i don't even want to go
in that direction
all i'm asking is you're one of the 12
you're one of you know
you're sitting there with the jurors yes
you're asking the group
doors closed nine hours on something
what is it nine hours and 45 minutes
whatever the timeline was right there
and making the decision right you're
sitting there
is anyone asking what the hell is going
to happen to america if we let this guy
go a hundred percent you think someone
asked that nine hours and what do you
think do you think somebody said oh it's
gonna be crazy
so do you think it was one of those
things where they don't want to be a
part of that
do you think it's one of those things
that where one person's life
is less important than us having rights
is that the right way of thinking okay
so so
i think it is okay you think it is how
okay so tell me why if it was your life
would you want that
you want me to sacrifice you you didn't
do nothing wrong if i'm
if number one i think the jury actually
he want to be a roman in the days of
jesus
actually that crucified jesus just for
the hell of it right you'd be that
person
you're out of control bro i'm just
telling you i can see you in roman
uniform killing jesus
you're a roman brother go all day go
with yourself so do you think the
conversation was brought up okay listen
let's just relax for a second i think
the jury
actually sat there it's very easy to be
like oh i think this bro and i think
this bro
bro and this is what i think bro i think
i actually think
that they actually sat there and
listened to all the experts that were
called in
for days and days and days and weeks and
they and when an expert says yes
if someone has a knee on your neck and
this is what happens to the heart
and the heart and the palpitations you
can understand the centrifugal force and
like
they actually sit there and listen to
the science go on and on and on and on
for days i think they say
how much it did they had a video where
he had his knee on his back
they didn't they watched that ricky gets
his name how much
how much of the decision how much of the
decision you think was
justice how much of the decision was
america is going to be so flippant
divided it's going to be insane
i think that's what i think the large
percentage of it was
actual the facts of the case i do think
okay so you're putting it more there
okay well beyond okay i also think that
there was
an emotional component to saying you
know what
don't forget they all have to agree i
mean if the one dissents
yeah then the whole thing is a hung jury
so i think there's probably
like we talked about lo you know logic
and emotion i think there's someone
who's thinking you know what
i don't know but i'm not you know what
sacrifice the sacrificial lamb chauvin
i'm not trying to see america burn i'm
sure people think like that
and you know what i'm okay with it in
this case
sorry call me the judas whatever you i
don't want to see america burn
because this scumbag chauvin maybe or
maybe not
had his knee on his back versus his neck
so forget about uh forget about uh
innocent
uh till proven guilty and then without
reasonable doubt right
i think uh uh uh first of all on that
specific topic
of listen if we can avoid this from
happening
let's find this guy guilty to prevent
all the rights from happening that's
catastrophic
also find him guilty on one charge they
don't have to go all the trees
clearly that shows that he was guilty i
get that so but but if that's the
motivation the fear
this is exactly where i'm going to the
following
okay which was what naivete yep too much
trust in one person lack of fiscal
responsibility
a war laziness uh uh
uh what was the other one a um
entertainment education
a spirit of division and the last one's
values and principles right
this kind of stuff leads to the kind of
war that we
definitely don't want to have in america
which is what the worst kind of work
not only a race war a civil war it is
absolutely
ludicrous to see this going to that
direction because just yesterday we all
know what happened by the way this is
nancy pelosi's comments about the event
she said uh nancy pelosi under fire for
saying george floyd sacrificed
himself for justice that's another
newsweek story speaker the house nancy
pelosi was criticized on social media
tuesday after she thanked george
for sacrificing his life for justice
pelosi said thank you george floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice
for being there to call out
uh to your mom how heartbreaking was
that call out to your mom i can't
breathe but because of your
because of you and because of thousands
millions of people around the world who
come out of justice
your name will be synonymous with
justice pelosi's was quickly denounced
for her remarks
with many users pointing out that floyd
did not voluntarily give up
his life for justice nancy pelosi just
said thank you george floyd for
sacramento
and this is a nutshell is everything
that's wrong with
uh fox woke liberalism conservative talk
liberalism conservative talk shows dan
o'donnell tweeted so
she gives these thoughts right on what
it is jesus
well that's kind of what she's uh
unbelievable yeah to make a comment like
that yeah i think that's absurd okay so
that's absurd
now that leads to the event that
happened
yesterday this is before before we move
on to the next topic let's get our
audience involved why don't
we do a poll or you know you do the
thumbs up thumbs down ask them what they
think should he be guilty i mean
how do you i don't know how you want to
pose the question with the thumbs up
thumb down so i'm just asking you to do
it but okay
so did you did you agree
with the verdict of what happened if yes
thumbs up
did you not agree with the verdict of
what happened thumbs down and i'm
talking specifically smash the thumbs up
or the thumbs down right now we're at
452 to
3 is what the ratios are 452 to 3.
i'll see these things myself because
okay so now 450 two to three
it just went up uh uh ten to one people
say they agree with the verdict
yeah okay our audience is reasonable
they they agree with the version unlike
hold on hold on go ahead go ahead am i
being unreasonable or i'm just stating
the fact that there could be more
evidence to it you're not you're not no
no i'm being honest you're not being
unrealistic i'm playing
you actually because i i said that i'm
divided on it because if the reality is
if there's evidence
that his net his foot was not on the or
his knee was not on the neck then what
are you gonna do about that
just to your point do you think his knee
on his back
is any better than his neck of course a
hundred times better
if you're on a if you're on the ground
and someone's pushing on your back and
your chest is
against the right the the curb on the
and you're and you also can't breathe
like the guy couldn't breathe no no
brother was on his neck that's what it
was on his throat
he couldn't breathe that's where i agree
with you because when he's saying i
can't breathe you got to really look
into that
yes you already got them surrounded look
it's the same thing that happened with
eric i don't agree with what happened
with that
cigarettes that's disgusting yes okay if
you don't mind sam do we have that
do we got that ready uh pat do you mind
if i give uh our friend uh
uh uh before we continue right now i got
something yeah absolutely okay you gotta
pay your bet
sam so what do you got here bro i told
him i asked him
i asked him if i could give him a down
payment right on the thousand dollars
that i owe you so i got
three hundred dollars worth of quarterly
is my first down payment to you sir
uh you know and the reason i can't give
you the other 700 right now
is because your president that you voted
for is gonna tax me highly so i have to
tax you as well so that being said i
have three hundred dollars worth of
quarters
i believe in the tax system the way you
do laundry for life this is
this is three hundred dollars worth of
quarters i'd like to count it out and
stack up
you can use it however you like okay
okay and it's uh
it's currency i thought it was going to
be pennies because if it was pennies
you would have been in trouble right now
so but let me tell you we can you can
take this you can take this down to food
max they have a coin machine where
actually we'll convert this into dollars
okay okay and then and then uh uh after
i do my taxes we can figure out how i
could do the other 700 for you all right
sounds like a plan so now we're but i
got to dump
yesterday i asked you bill by the way at
dinner i asked you can i give you a
dollar did you even come back bro
to mario and sam for doing unbelievable
but my question to you is
last night i asked you can i give you a
down payment and you said yes
so this is my down payment we're talking
about somebody who makes probably a half
a million dollars more than that
if not more he lost a bet legitimately
legitimately he lost a bet he's been
ducking me
for for a good four months
pat paid day off
he makes this much money he can't give
me a thousand brothers listen
to the audience tens of thousands
you were there when i gave uh so here's
what our friend marvin invited ten
thousand dollars because i lost
i know how to pay my bets but i asked
you specifically yes if i could give you
a down payment
yes yes but you said yes here's my
downfall i've been asking you for four
months hey
he's a thousand yeah he said like you're
dealing with without payment you guys
got to figure out this issue this is
between the two of you guys you got your
quarters to go accountable
please hold that so i'm going to charge
you 10 interest every day on the
remaining 700 okay
so that's 70 bucks a day let's continue
let's continue go back to this okay
fantastic let's leave that over here so
let's let's go
let's go to what happened
let's look at what happened in ohio
let's look at the ohio story kai if you
want to bring that up
ohio police kill black teenage girls
seen
threatening others with knife this is
reuters story police in columbus ohio
on tuesday fatally shot a black teenage
girl they confronted as
she uh lunged at two people with a knife
as seen in a police video footage of the
counter authority said authorities
described a teenager
who was fatally shot at 15 years old
that's 15 years old but family members
have identified her
mckee brian age 16 the police officer
who opened fire
was not identified but appears from the
video to be white the interim columbus
police chief michael wood said the
officer would be taken off the street
pending an investigation releasing
a police body camera video of tuesday's
shooting hours later wood said officers
involved were responding to a 9-1-1
emergency call
from someone who reported an attempted
stabbing at a home
on the city's south side uh
southeast side if you have the video to
just show this go ahead kai just to
count if you can flip the camera so we
can stop it
if you can flip the screen for the
screen to be bigger than us and when
we're ready go right ahead
go ahead buddy
get down
wow
stop if you stop the video okay uh that
was she wasn't threatening she was
getting ready to stab that girl
that was not a threat can you go back to
to exactly right before
is there uh there's pictures of it okay
go back and pull up the pictures to see
if there's pictures of this pictures of
it
and that that that teenage girl farther
far further than a threat that's for
damn sure
go to images
okay so that's the second one go to the
second one
click on it again that's cbs news
there's a knife right there what a
position to be in as a cop
that happening right in front of you
so say that again
especially as you're pulling up like
you're just getting for it to escalate
that quickly and how old is a cop 20 uh
20 some years old
how old was a cop a younger child okay
so what do you think when you see this
what's the first thing you think about
when you see this
he saved a young black girl's life
that's what he did she was
that that's a look how big that girl is
that she go she's gonna stab with force
and the other girl's skinny
she's gonna stab her with force that's
not slashing
she's going straight for a direct hit
and look how big that knife is pat
what is that six seven inches maybe we
can't see it we don't want to speculate
but
it's a good six inches look at it look
at her grip
uh on it it's a six probably five or six
inch that's gonna kill this girl
i mean that's that's the cop did what he
was supposed to do
yeah i don't know i just want to go back
to my initial point de-escalate the
police he just ran up he saw something
going down
how many how many shots did he fire if
we could
i i saw i heard at least three or four
shots if you saw if
bro if we're looking at this through a
camera we can see the knife imagine what
he could see live
he's watching that knife it's so obvious
i think i don't think anything is
obvious at this point because i think
the facts need to play out
clearly she has a knife you need more
effects than that that's crazy what if
it was yours
is that a butter knife is that a is that
is that a machete i don't know what that
is
okay i'll put you this way what if that
was your daughter on the other side of
the night would you want to care
to see if it was a butter knife it was a
fake knife would you want it would you
care
here's the question if it was my
daughter's i'm not here i'm not i'm not
picking sides here i have questions i
don't have answers i don't have
solutions here i've got a lot of
freaking questions
why does the cop need to roll up and
just bang bang bang take someone's life
that's exactly what he did what are you
doing the cop rolled up the girl
fell go back to the video at the
beginning go back to the video at the
beginning this is just a question
back like original when he comes in go
all the way to the beginning just press
play from the beginning he's not running
out of his card
i'm gonna slow it down yeah puts a speed
put point five yeah there you go
okay he comes out he has no idea
everything looks peaceful so far
the girl is standing there in the pink
okay
somebody falls down
[Applause]
then he draws his gun oh
oh i got it so got it so that's a cop
right there by the way
yeah already in the middle who has not
drawn his gun
okay so that cop is going to have a
perspective yeah but but here's the
here's the
in that situation you have one of two
choices if you don't shoot
somebody who's about to kill another
stab another person right in front of
you
then you allowed somebody to be stabbed
it is a very technical situation here on
what to do
you might know the answer to this what's
that why can't you shoot her in the leg
or in the arm or in the ass why do you
need to take someone off
hold on hold on they actually did a
study and it's funny that you say that
because i was watching this study
yesterday
last night in my hotel comps are not me
they're not taught to shoot and
here's the logical side behind it he
says we don't teach to shoot the leg or
the arm
because it's such a small target that's
moving
if that cop misses that bullet goes past
the
plaster person and he can kill somebody
else that has nothing to do with the
innocent
so they says we teach them to shoot to
the biggest body mass
because the per person typically is
getting shot
is in the action of committing a crime
if we go for the leg or the arm
okay and i'm moving he's just p and the
the it was interesting with the cops
people can't even hit targets that are
still at a gun range
let alone somebody that's moving around
you shoot towards the leg
that that bullet ricochets and it hits
an innocent person now you're looking at
shooting somebody that's innocent
they have to go to the biggest body mass
to make sure that those bullets do not
go past anybody that makes it that's a
reasonable explanation that makes sense
but watch watch go to the tweet go to
the tweet of what
uh newsom what newsome not not governor
newsom there's a tweet uh
uh that uh let me see if this yeah so
uh uh brie newsome said teenagers have
been having a dream
by the way huh who's bree newsome bree
newsome uh she's an advocate for
building
don't click on it because if you do
you're gonna lose a tweet
teenagers have been having fights
including fights involving knives for
eons
we do not need police to address these
situations by showing up to the scene
and using a weapon against one of the
teenagers you all need help
i mean that's sincerely unbelievable go
click on the foundation she has 200
retweets
it's not even that she's got more than
200 retweets this is a person that's got
000 followers artist grassroots
organizer
free black woman scale 30 feet flagpole
a remove south carolina
confederate flag in protest in june 27
so she's uh proud of that so
that's uh that's kind of the place where
we are right now so cops now don't get
involved in
knife fights okay what are you supposed
to do this one the reasons why i called
bernard carrick this morning him and i
were having a conversation this morning
bernard carrick was a former
head of the nypd for years he was the
guy that helped clean new york with
mayor giuliani back in the days when new
york had the whole
situation going on he was the guy was
not easy being bernard you have to be
just as strong of a personality to go up
against the mob and go up against
everybody else and
carrick was pretty much that scary of a
guy in the streets where if he came out
people knew something was going on
and he sees this he says what are you
doing a situation like that so
let's talk solutions let's talk
solutions somebody here commented
something very interesting
somebody commented here let me read it
to you uh and
gave 20 bucks let me see if i can find
this guy ah man i wish i would i thought
i
took a screenshot somebody said okay
here we go
all of the suited and booted 20 bucks
all of this attention on police has an
end game of robocop coming in and
policing the public
this would protect the assets of the
rich much more protection without human
emotion
also much more submission think about
that right there
okay so every time a cop comes
lebron sends a tweet and lebron says
what he puts up a tweet that he takes
down
momentarily because the backlash he got
he puts the saying you're next okay and
obviously time clock accountability he
takes it down
then he has his next tweet if you want
to read out his next tweet i don't know
if you have it or not if you don't have
it
uh maybe he removed it or not but he has
a couple of
he got so much heat for this yesterday
and he says i'm so damn tired uh i've
seen black people killed by police i
took the tweet down because it's being
used to create more hate this isn't
about one officer it's about the entire
system and they always use
our words to create more racism i'm so
desperate for more
accountability right what an idiot yeah
so so that's lebron james
on what you got so how do you solve this
how do you solve this
you know how do you how do you prevent
emotions from taking place what do you
do like you see that one movie where
everything is
you know perpetuating like right before
crime is about to happen
minority minority report where they
catch you you know
is the solution having billions of
cameras on the streets which we already
have but i'm talking like the government
having billions of cameras on the street
is the solution more surveillance so
what are you really asking for
right the same person that said you know
black teenage
black kids have been using knives for
the long eons you know leave them alone
let them handle in the streets
themselves
if you go back and read what she says
she's for getting
rid of cops and letting communities take
take care of themselves without cops
being involved
is that really the right solution is
technology the solution
is is more control the solution is more
cameras the solution
we were reading a book this month called
the speed of trust
and i had my executives reading this
book and in the book it talked about
what tsa did
when tsa came out in 2001 uh november of
2001 right after 9 11 happened under
president bush administration they came
up with tsa
they said what ended up happening is it
used to take 30 minutes for you to get
on your flight when you would go to the
airport now it's 90 minutes
because we don't trust more it's now
90 minutes to go on a flight then it
used to be 30 minutes
of what people used to do so they took
60 minutes away from people that are
busy trying to be productive trying to
work
trying to get to their places simply
because we don't trust so if we go in
the direction of trying to find a
solution for this
it's gonna have to come up at a price of
giving up something
is that giving up your freedom of being
monitored and watched non-stop
is it more camera is it you know robocop
type of deal is it
are we going and having you know uh
these these
uh what do you call it robot type of in
the whole robocop things being placed
everywhere that scene what's happening
what becomes a solution for something
like this i don't know what the solution
is but something that just kind of
crossed my mind i don't think we need
more cameras more surveillance i don't
think we need more big brother i don't
think we need a george orwellian 1984
type situation that's not what i think
but
getting back to the lebron thing and the
accountability i wonder i wonder
and this is something i probably never
even said out loud and i just kind of
thought about it but
imagine if that girl would have actually
stabbed
the other girl um black on black that
would have been a black on like if she
would have died that would have been a
black on black crime right
would love would have lebron said
anything no would
uh anyone have said anything no would
i mean black people get killed by other
black people in chicago
all the time and i get that that's a
major concern people do talk about it
anyone who says well they don't talk
about it they're probably wrong because
people do talk about it alone who talks
about it
it's a it's a thing that people talk who
talks about specifically everyone knows
everyone no absolutely not so nobody
talks about it not not not cnn
not msnbc everyone has talked about okay
let me ask
let me ask you a question for every one
minute that they've spent
talking about that black on black crime
how much have they spent talking about
white on black crime okay cool
that that's where i was going with this
so i wasn't even talking about what's
the race talking about police on
what's the ratio 101 20 to 140 to one
because
yes yes okay yes yes remember one of the
seven reasons for
fallen of an empire is to create a
division amongst the country and that's
the media
i can go on the media rail about the
media and the division that they're
causing
for the rest of the show but ultimately
my point is this
those were two black people fighting
yeah they could have been two white
people it could have been two hispanics
could have been two jews whatever but
that's
the facts of this case those were two
black people fighting okay if the black
one bigger black girl killed the
skinnier of the black girl
where would have been the outrage what
would have been the yeah it wouldn't
have been anything you wouldn't even
heard about it
that's my point that's ultimately my
point that's why i said i'm probably
saying something that people have been
like whoa what the [ __ ] he talking
about
so that's point number six the
the the reality is what's worse
what's worse a civilian killing another
civilian
black on black crime in this particular
instance or a cop rolling up
quote-unquote doing his job and killing
the person
the perpetrator in this case who has a
weapon in her hand
and he already says back up back up back
up so one way or another someone was
gonna die
what's worse the the the one girl
killing another girl
or the cop killing socially i'm just
saying that that's the reality that
there's different angles socially or
justice or or justice wise
i'm posing the question but the reality
is she had a knife
no no that's not is it justice or is it
or is it socially
is it justice or is it social is it just
if you're talking about justice
what's worse or is it socially what's
worse because we're obviously seeing
what socially is the worst
thing they're calling him a racist and
that now i don't i don't think he's a
look i don't think he's a racist he just
rolled up and he saw some i don't know
this person we don't
nobody knows him the facts will kind of
play out i think he was
put in a difficult situation like i
talked about initially
cops who are 25 years old that guy
looked pretty young he might be 30 i
don't know
they're asked to be to de-escalate
situations they're asked to be
negotiators they're asked to be
paramedics and emts and they're asked to
do so much
and in the middle of all that you gave a
great explanation of why he had to shoot
for the body and kill somebody
um they're asked to do so much so
the i don't you can't just say oh he's
racist
he's white he killed her he's racist no
she had a knife in her hand bro
so i'm just posing the question like
someone was gonna mo
likely die like if if if he would have
stabbed if she would have stabbed the
other girl
it would have just been another story in
the newspaper no big deal
because the cop did it no one would it's
the front page so so okay
so this is now leading me to one area of
the freedom that we have in america
that's become a problematic lately by
the way somebody said a couple things
here
i want to read a couple of the comments
one of them um
you can read it on your own by bobby
collins he's not happy what you said he
says i love you but you're uh
uh how can you question this clear video
but the george floyd was a clear day
uh clear as day bobby collins is calling
you out and calling
calling calling you out saying clear as
day clears day video what happened with
george floyd and another person said
no no hold on hold on the video that was
shown by the media or the actual videos
by the journalist read this comment
right here
uh and adam
a third say they disagree with the
verdict two thirds
agree with the vote okay from this
audience two thirds hold on hold on
hold on hold on yeah but hold on you can
you can you can and and this is and this
is the reality behind things
just because a lot of the mass agreed
doesn't mean it's right okay so
maybe here remember this the majority of
people
are waiting why do you want to defend
yourself listen to me listen to me
yeah most of people wake up in the
morning they make their coffee they make
their breakfast they do it they send
their they go to work they send their
kids to school they come back and they
have after school activities
the majority is most people both on the
right and the left
are not sitting there doing their
homework on this all they watch was was
shown to them on the media
that's the reality behind things so you
can still be
you can you can say you can be on one
side of the political spectrum
and still believe the narrative that was
pushed i'm not defending
i'm talking about in general you can
believe the narrative that was pushed
because right now there's a narrative
being pushed by lebron james
and this other lady whatever her name
was that that was a little
innocent girl that is mostly a
peacemaker like her mom said stabbing
another girl
and if you don't look into it you'll
believe that so i don't care if the
masses believe something
the reality is there is another video
with another angle
with the man having his knee on his back
that is reality that you don't like it
because here mark twain said it's easier
to fool people than to make them
it is easier to fool people that to
convince them they have been fooled
okay that's what mark twain says is the
fact that you can still be on one
side of the political spectrum and and
believe
what was pushed on you on both sides
because you don't know the truth
so the truth is you don't know the truth
so to think that something's clear is
they
no [ __ ] no it's not clear because
you don't know the other side because
you haven't done your homework on it
so now on this side what the what the
gentleman was trying to tell you was
on one side you're like yeah yeah yeah
he killed him you see a knife and
somebody's being stabbed and you're like
well i don't know why did you just get
off and bang bang
like that doesn't i understand where
he's coming from like
i don't know what this guy's point was
his point is that on what is clear
this is not clear
a girl right here almost getting
stabbing you're not clear about it bro
i just said i don't like this video
she has a knife in your hand that's all
we know oh that's all so it's not going
in a certain direction it's not hanging
at somebody right
yes okay aimed at the other girl i just
i just basically said someone was gonna
get murdered
no no you didn't ricky stop it
stop it bro i don't know your point let
me let me read this other one somebody
said why don't you just tase them
instead of shooting them
jimmy kalut said why don't you taste her
instead of shooting her because it goes
backpack yeah
right but you have a little girl what if
what if she was on the other side of the
knife would you want to tease her again
there's no question about it that's what
i'm saying it's easy to take absolutely
i'm just reading the comment a person
said
drew mega just said as a son of two
jamaican parents i think the cop was
justifiable
he saved her by milliseconds he's more
of a hero than a villain
he's not a villain at all yeah mark
marine mark marine mark the mariner
cop shoots girl attacking dies girl
saved cop
doesn't shoot girl dies attacker dies
other people possibly injured or killed
cop possibly dies or is injured by a
deadly weapon
you know you know who the most important
perspective on this entire thing is
what's that who's the most important
perspective that we want to hear of
out of this entire situation no who
the girl that's about to get stabbed i'd
love to hear what she has that would not
be a bad idea actually i would love to
hear what she has to say see if i can
get a hold of her okay
see that's the person we need to hear
from if she says
no i was about to get killed the cops
saved my life that's an interesting
perspective
but if by chance yeah she says no the
cop came in he didn't have to kill her
she was my friend we had a little fight
that's a totally different person damn
that's crazy i've had a little fight
with my friends not gonna try to stop me
that's crazy okay well i mean good
congratulations on having friends
i don't know what happened there the
point is the one perspective we do need
to hear from is the girl who's
you need a person you need a perspective
after watching the video it's funny you
don't need a perspective with traveling
but now you need a perspective here i
don't know why you're so
focused on defending shout outs because
you're basically saying
well his knee was on his back so it's
okay well his name is still on his
goddamn bed that's a huge difference for
his knee on his neck
now when you're not when you're pinned
on the ground and against against the
curb
you're acting like well his knee was on
his back so no big deal ricky that's
that's the same
ricky did say if you got a guy in
handcuffs why are you putting the knee
on the guy okay
you already said that uh you're
basically saying because okay you did
say that but you're also saying this
knee was on his back it's not a big deal
all i'm saying is you're super adamant
about one but you're not adamant about
the other why do you need a perspective
if somebody's getting stabbed i don't
need a perspective i'm going to shoot
the person that's possibly going to be
harming the other person there's no
perspective to look at the girl has a
knife and she's in full
she helps back she's in full swing to
stop this girl there is no perspective
bro that's that's that's all there is to
it so she should have died
off well you're going to kill somebody
else and that was my point if someone
was no that was not your point
i did say that it's a black on black
crime point yes that's okay
you're gonna be all right yeah i need
700 more dollars in quarters immediately
all right so this
this uh this is uh i get tax on it so
you will too
this is a this is a very interesting
thing because the
the part that's a bit confusing is the
following adam when
sometimes you hear when somebody uses
uh a gun to protect somebody that guy
is a you know the cop is doing that he's
the criminal right what he's doing but
if on the other side
if you hear on the uh uh somebody that
kills uh a black that kills others
sometimes you hear all its mental issues
you know he had mental problems he had
gun it's the gun's fault
accountability is very contradictory
right it's very contradictory it's only
what story can be used to
validate your story to spin to divide
even more and and the part where i was
going with this was the following here's
where i was going with this
before you know you guys had your
discourse you know
the freedoms that america gives are what
freedom of speech freedom of
assembly freedom of enterprise you know
freedom of all this stuff second
religion
don't forget religion that's right it's
your top one so freedom of religion all
these things that it does right
there there is an issue with press for
me
there isn't an issue with press for me
you have an issue with free traffic
there's an issue with press like oh yeah
yeah let me give you an idea what i mean
by there's an issue with press
who who is the press accountable to
nobody and i know it's the people
obviously it's the people that hold the
press accountable right
you can't say this you can't say that
you can't say this but
let me tell you man right now the the
press doesn't have a lot of pushback the
press doesn't have a lot of
accountability the press doesn't have a
lot of uh
you know in the nba you say something
about the referee get fined
in the envy you say something about the
referee the leak finds you right
in the media you get to say anything
there are no fines
very rarely do you hear this person was
suspended for one day you know like even
what what happened with uh back in the
days with the comedian
chappelle when they're like why are you
going a little bit too much you know i
think we gotta
shut him down right he's like i'm just
done i'm gonna take a break and he comes
back
hitting hard again right where is the
press being held accountable for this
where's the press being held accountable
for pushing a story for three years that
was a lie and then they say ah
it's not a big okay let's talk about
what's going on today and they just move
on where's the level of accountability
for the press
these are the guys that we these are
journalists they went to school to be
journalists right i mean they go to
school to be
a journalist these guys get paid to get
on camera and report to us what's going
on this is what they get paid to do
and they take a story like this and they
just spin it to the way they
want it and then boom america divides
it's a v
if if i were if you were to tell me what
is your biggest concern long term
what's your biggest concern long term
you know that bree newsome that said
well you know all this stuff racism you
know
we've been using knives against each
other for eons just kind of leave us
alone
or aoc that goes out there this is just
a injustice that's taking place
and lebron hey who's next your next this
is a person like lebron with the kind of
influence you got to put the guy's
picture
and you say you're next you put the guys
there's an emotion
that's that by the way by the way that
that's somebody's life but he's not
gonna get suspended
twitter's not gonna go do anything to
him and that's okay why
so the level of accountability is not he
potentially put this man
you realize that somebody's that's
somebody's kid as well
that we're talking about you put his
picture on blast saying
you're next not saying anything like
you know hey uh
it's unfair what happened today you know
you're next
in the world of what you're next means
to a lot of people
your next has a lot of interpretations
and by the way
yep to the wrong person who's a die-hard
lebron fan
and says you know what yeah yeah you're
next let me find this mother you know
yep
you got to be careful so i think same
thing with a die-hard trump fan when
they
do all that well no but he was held
accountable though that's true so but
he's not held accountable we'll see
what we will see we'll see what do you
mean we'll see your tweets already
happened
okay i don't think anything will happen
but we'll see what happens if lebron
nobody nothing is going to happen
you're likely but back to your initial
point yeah so you went from press to
lebron
i think you just how like when trump
tweets something and you know the fact
check and
everything that happened with that i
think there does need to be a clear
distinction these days
between fact-based journalism and
opinion-based journalism so i think
if we're going to go there i think when
hannity does a show
or when don lemon does a show it should
say
opinions of this person or opinion
journalism or when wolf blitzer does a
show
or when neil cavuto does a show these
will say
okay i mean tucker is opinion yeah but
there's certain journalists who are
fact-based and they're certain
journalists are opinion-based
and there was no clear distinction for a
long time and i think at this point at
this point like if you do
the fox news hour between lauren ingram
tucker carlson um juan hannity
these are all opinions even the the the
five these are all opinions yeah same
thing for cnn you got cuomo
you've got um brooke baldwin and you've
got these are all opinions these are not
fact-based journalists i don't know let
me in the wall street journal though usa
today you do have to attract questions
let me ask you a question let me ask a
question you think if
we went on a five-year diet
of showing stuff on the news
recognizing unifiers recognizing voice
of reason
recognizing people that are willing to
sit with opposing side and have a debate
or discourse
debate or discourse do you think people
would be inspired to want to be that
more
versus if we turned a
divider like lebron into a hero
if we turn dividers into heroes
everybody looks at the playbook and says
i want to also be a divider yep because
that's who we're turning into a hero
kids are growing up saying i want to be
a divider because that's what pays i
want to be divided because that's what
celebrity
i want to be a divider i think i think
we you disagree with that i don't think
anybody says
i want to be a divider i think they say
i want to stand up for what i believe
and based on those beliefs the
difference between standards you're
going to you're going to pick a side
listen nobody says i want to divide
people listen i'm a christian
i'm a christian i consider myself a
christian okay
but you have no idea how skeptical
skeptical of a christian i am
you have no idea so i don't sit there if
you ask
any of the christian mentors in my life
what is it like when you talk to pat
they'll tell you
this guy's like what about this and what
about this and what about this and what
about this one what about this
i don't sit here and say no matter what
dude reason little bit of reasonable
person but what i'm saying is we need to
recognize that element in the world
to get more kids to also want to reason
that is what we're not recognizing
enough of
recognizing the hero that's sitting
there saying i don't
know versus that's not fair jump into
conclusion emotion
turn him into a hero i want to be like
him so i think it's a great idea how do
you implement that how do you implement
no it's not going to happen it's not
going to happen it's not about how you
implement it doesn't sell
it's not going to happen because it
doesn't
match the narrative there's no way
that'll happen because it doesn't match
the narrative
it's it's no way in the world there's
something that's going to sit there and
say well no no
we can't do that because we're not
pushing our agenda more we're not
pushing our agenda more
pushing out gender more i'm going to
make my prediction to hear today
you know what else happens every time
there's a possibility of an empire
fallen you know what else happens every
time there's a possibility of empire
falling
guess what happens every single time
history repeats itself and crap like
this happens guess what happens
a whole new wave of leaders are born
every time
every time a guy who's tatted up
who has the background that he has gets
inspired pre-he and i meeting you were
never into any capitalism politics
anything
ricky was a guy to himself and now
ricky's out there voice being for the
latino community why because he's
sitting there saying
i can reason with this you're going to
see the kind of leaders that are going
to be raised up the next 10
20 years like we've never seen before
like we've never seen before
but the direction we're going right now
america's naive if they don't see how
we're being divided right now
purely pathetic what they're doing to us
right now pinning people against each
other you cannot fall for it
unfortunately america is falling forward
and when you say they are you're talking
about the media who else specifically
who else would it be outside of the
media and politicians who else would it
be media politicians people with voices
and perspectives
not iran's not media lebron's not
apologize absolutely media yeah
lebron is mean so anybody's immediately
lebron was a media company he raised a
hundred million dollars greenhouse what
do you mean he's not media so
okay is anthony davis media
like if we're gonna go there who's
anthony who's anthony david that's a
role model
okay so that's wrong just because lebron
had so was lebron media before he had a
media
company lebron's probably been media for
the last five years because he's been a
guy that's uh uh
uh so if you have a big voice your media
yeah that's influence
so you can be on social media and you
can be media right is that what you're
saying
you could be media but you got to you
got to use your platform to bring
people to the center to have a discourse
like you know people say
pat the day you fire adam is the day i
watch
the podcast yeah you're an idiot for
saying something like that
what do you mean today i fire adam i'm
gonna be on the podcast you know i
cannot believe you gave a socialist a
platform and you brought dan price on
i'm gonna bring him on again
i can't believe you brought richard
wolff socialist professor
who believes in socialism and wants to
make america socialist why would you
bring him on your show
i'll bring him 50 more times i'll bring
him 50 more
why would you have a conversation with
the communist libya slavoji
because that's how we are able to reason
and see leaks in the argument and then
you get to make a decision for yourself
but that's not what it is today today
it's let me just bring
everybody that's on my side to validate
my point
not the other way around we need a
little bit of resistance unfortunately
we're not getting a lot of
yeah resistance today anyways how about
we talk about elon musk the story of
elon musk
entrepreneur okay magazine to go to a
little bit of a a different kind of a
story all right here we go
elimos proclaims himself as emperor of
mars
entrepreneur the co-founder of private
space exploration
company spacex elamos noted that the key
to preventing the extinction of animals
and planets on earth lies
on mars in a tweet this weekend elon
musk remarked that if we managed to make
life interplanetary it will not matter
if it becomes extinct on earth page 3
because it will live on the red planet a
few days ago musk took advantage of the
excitement
caused by the company's reusable robots
to proclaim himself
in his tweets biography twitter
biography as emperor of mars it should
be remembered that musk
constantly changes his description on
the social network and has called
himself currency
advisor as in game of thrones because of
his internet
interest in digital currencies such as
dodge dogecoin
so adam what are you thinking about uh
elon musk being the emperor of mars
uh kai real quick give uh ricky your
notes you he's got the notes from yeah
all right nobody will
um number one shout out to earth
shout out to earth it's probably my
favorite planet that i've ever been on
um shout out to earth today is earth day
so
i know that elon musk is obsessed with
mars and kudos to him for that
and i know that he's the proclaimed
emperor of mars and respect i know that
he's banging martians
and he's terri and he turned his
girlfriend into an alien i get it
but just shout out to you say that what
do you mean by that have you not seen
what she looks like i sincerely don't
know what to do
okay you don't know what alien yes i
don't know what to do
kai pull up um our friend uh
uh what's her name again grimes pull up
grimes
this is um elon musk i think he's a v
let me get let me give you the
to use a dogecoin reference that that's
his girl that's his girl
um oh yeah you're into that uh
ricardo myself down in uh michigan this
is how you get down or no
okay i didn't think so so let's give the
uh the different sides of dogecat he's a
visionary
he's a dreamer he's a big thinker he's
an absolute billionaire
respect he's toying with people though
though
mars but i think he also yeah he might
be toying with people but i also think
he does have some sort of a god complex
we talked about that last night i think
he's getting a little
too otherworldly for his own good i
think
he's doing a lot of good things i'm an
elon musk fan but i
do think he's kind of getting you know
what but you know what though but you
know what here
i don't think anybody he nobody should
be a software team i don't think he's
even made that statement
but i did say he's the emperor of mars
no emperor being an emperor and consider
yourself a god or two different things i
said he's got a god complex okay what
i'm getting bro
in order to do what this man has done
you you've got to be kind of you got to
be nuts
so i said he's a little crazy and a
little cookie and he's a visionary i
don't know i know i'm not saying i'm
just
i'm just saying like you got to be you
got to be off in order to be able to do
what he's been able to do because you
have to have an imagination and
creativity that's
beyond you know beyond the normal person
you know i i i like it i keep calling
himself whatever i like it i'm a big
elon musk fan
i think that uh i like that he doesn't
bother you at all you're cool with it
yeah
you think he's toying trolling with
people you think he's kind of i think so
as well
he's he's that's for the same reason i'm
a big six knight fan pat yeah
six nine fans i had so much respect for
you
bro he's because then you go out and do
something like this oh
he went and totally redeemed it this guy
went and he snitched on people for the
right
you know for whatever reasons he did
right or wrong reasons and then he comes
out and he's a millionaire again
because he just rattles the cage so much
it's cool with the snake yeah
no no i'm not cool with the snitching
i'm cool with him rattling the cage i
like that
but from where you're from if you know
one of your people came in
okay yeah so you're cool with them no i
don't i don't know where you're at with
this no i'm just saying i like that he's
a disrupter i like that he doesn't care
i like that takashi let me read the
other part about him
he was a secret service special agent
when he donated to the republican party
and fec filing shows business inside
elon musk has already
changed his title at tesla's tech techno
techno king and now he's claiming to
work for secret service
the tech billionaire donated 990 to the
republican national committee across
january 7th and 8th and listed to
his job as special agent at the u.s
secret service new federal
election commission filing show there's
no evidence that musk has any connection
to the u.s secret service he has
obviously
previously listed aerospace company
spacex as his employer on political
donations
oh my god so my question is he's smoking
that january
january 7th and 8th of what year
he's smoking that he's smoking that mars
weed this guy is
classic on what he's doing january 7th
8th of what year doesn't say just say
january if it's says january 7th and 8th
that means it's this year
okay so that means you've donated to the
republican dollars so what's your number
it's a weird night it's a weird dude
but you did it the day after the
insurrection at the capitol
that happened january 6th so that after
that he said i gotta give money to these
[ __ ] over here like what but
990 what's the the the night i know that
he's got it
there's a code behind a knife of course
he prices things at 420.
he's a weird out there crazy visionary
that likes banging aliens and that's it
that's what you're sticking to i'm
sticking to it until he
proves otherwise let's talk about
vanessa bryan nike opt out
vanessa bryan nike opt not to renew
nearly 20 or long-term
long partnership over different
differences this is a fox business story
vanessa brown and kobe bryant's estate
decided not to extend their partnership
with nike which expired earlier this
month due to several differences between
the two sides
sources told espn that bryant and the
state were frustrated with the limited
availability of
brian's products and more significantly
that nike presented them with an offer
that was not in line with the
expectations of a lifetime deal similar
to those of michael jordan of
lebron james bryant originally signed
with nike in o3 the estate is now free
to negotiate a deal with new
brands what do you think about that
interesting
i thought it was the other way around i
thought nike didn't want to continue it
anymore
well they were not happy about the offer
so vanessa and the estate said we're not
interested
so nike made an offer but it wasn't the
rich offer of a jordan over lebron james
and they kind of
turned away well i think what's what's
pretty clear uh if you read anything
about this story is that
kobe rest in power um legend
uh is that he wanted to leave nike and
start his own mamba brand
much like the air jordan whether that's
under the nike umbrella or or not but
kobe look i think as amazing as a
basketball player as he was and he'll go
down as
top five top ten ever clearly right i
think mj
is number one kobe will
you know kareem russell whatever you
want to put him he's certainly in the
top five
shaq top ten i think he would have been
equally if not better businessman than
an athlete and the run rate would have
been
triple that what his nba career was
because by the time he retired it was in
his early 40s
and he had played for 20 years and i
think he would have had another 40
years plus of being a a businessman
a role model a dad a girl dad
alt i would i actually would have
respected his business
acumen more than his basketball acumen
because i think he would have changed
the world
business-wise and given an example um so
back to this
um i think he had a set of beliefs that
he wanted to
to abide by i think obviously vanessa
and the family knew about it
and i think you know don't be shocked if
a mamba brand comes out that's all i'm
saying
and you know i'm pat i'm sure you have a
perspective of
a very unique perspective on kobe
because you're the only person at the
table that actually sat with him for
hours on end and learn about his
perspective and his values and his
principles
but something that they talked about
here is a lifetime deal
but what happens when you're no longer
alive how do you bet on the athlete or
put people
behind the app that's no longer alive
yeah that's kind of what i was talking
to pat yesterday i mean he's
you know unfortunately he's he's not
with us anymore so how do you
you know how he can say you know jordan
is still thinking he does he did his
commercials even after he was out of the
nba
you know he's he's still you know he did
the last dance which brought him
you know he michael jordan is very much
alive with the older generation our
generation but the newer generation
they're like they're chris
uh they're uh uh uh for what uh
chris was for the golden state warriors
christopher curry steph curry they're
stephen
guys they're lebron james i don't know
basketball they're they're uh well i'm
just saying there's the newer generation
those are the things i think steph curry
is the best thing ever right right there
most exciting players which is true but
i think the last dance
you know solidified his right jordan's
legacy
which by the way something that's kobe
unfortunately is not going to be able to
do
you know 20 30 years from now he's done
with the league he's not going to be
able to relive through a last dance
series so uh yeah i mean i you know with
nike i i i can understand both sides of
it
he's not here anymore to push that and
and vanessa's not going to push you
she's not the driver
no that's true what's your perspective
on this story but also just bigger
business acumen yeah so i mean the real
question i got to ask is the following
there's no way in the world vanessa
bryan with all the advisors she has
around her that are dying you know like
full-on kobe fans are gonna steer her in
the wrong direction right
and there's no way you're breaking a
deal with nike without having an
alternative you're just not gonna do it
there's
no way in the world remember when
parlor fired the ceo the board did
and they fired the founder and we had a
meeting about five six months ago and i
said
if the board hires a ceo that gets
parlor back on the app
guess what the board gets credit for
bringing a better ceo and guess what
guess what happened apple is now
allowing parlor to get back on the board
get back on back onto aws and bait obs
which means that credit goes to
credit goes to the board for firing the
uh founder and ceo parlor respect there
to the founder being fired okay
to the board so in this situation
we're sitting here listening to this
vanessa bryant and her group may be
sitting there saying nike just
lost big time
so you know we learned worldwide how
much
kobe was loved let's just face it we
learned how much kobe was loved you know
you you realize how much you're loved
unfortunately you will never find out
how much you're loved
until you're you're dead the only people
that are going to know how much you're
loved is the day you die how many people
show up to your funeral and how
stories start showing up that nobody
knew about okay because those stories
don't show up until a person dies and
start telling these stories
a lot of them right yeah kobe died what
happened everybody stopped and everybody
started telling stories about kobe okay
um kobe started off with adidas if i'm
not mistaken when he first came into the
league
it wasn't nike i owned i think kobe had
an adidas shoe yep
i owned it today kobe's got what you got
today competition is to nike is who
under armour yeah you got uh
uh you got adidas where the hell is
reebok these days reebok is not going to
be the one that's going to play
play ball here but you got adidas and
you got
under armour okay and under armour is by
who today
under armour is they got dwayne johnson
they got a lot of guys if you look at
who under armour's got
and under armour's shoes today they're
actually good shoes i like under armour
shoes today not 20
not 10 years ago not five years ago i
wear under armour shoes today i also
wear nike
but i wear under armour shoes today is
it likely that someone's gonna pick this
deal up
i think so why because you know the
saying goes legends never
kobe is a hero he's a legend he's in a
league of his own i think somebody's out
there
already waiting to pick up this contract
that's willing to pay the massive
lifetime contract of
and a lifetime contract in this sense
could be a 50-year contract a 30-year
contract 100-year contract a 20-year
contract
because kobe's going to be relevant for
a very very long time to come he's not
going to be going away so
the shoes will be coming up you think
jordan's shoes are going to sell 50
years after jordan dies
yes 50 years after that oh man yeah
probably
okay yeah so so you you wear fergamos no
yeah do we know if ferragamo's a library
i have no idea
what i'm saying but you know the point
is he wears the louis
i don't even know who the vuitton they
are kobe is that big of a fig versace
what uh what story do you want to go to
next you wanted to go to a story with
uh brady let's go to the brady story
because it's on the same exact page so
tom brady says actions always speak
louder than words
pat mahomes fans say fans says fans will
find out in 20 years
who is better this is a daily caller
story tom brady says actions speak
louder than words and response to a
tweet about which athlete is better him
or pat
pat mahomes following the buccaneers
victory against the chiefs the back and
forth between the star qb
started with a tweet from kansas city
royals team which
included a video of royals catcher
salvador perez were in a number 12
jersey with the name brady on it the
catcher then looked at the camera
shook his finger and says pat mahomes is
the best the video perez wearing the
brady jersey stems from a super bowl
bet between salvador's former teammate
brett phillips the bet was that if bucks
won
perez would wear tampa bay jersey to
batting practice when the royals and
rays met
for the april for their april series at
kauffman stadium
and if the chiefs won phillips would
wear instead have to rock a kansas city
jersey the chief's qb mahomes
who's lost to the bucks 31-9 super bowl
said fans wouldn't know in 20 years who
is better so who is going to end up
being better
bro brady are you even like mahomes take
a step back guy
you've done nothing you've had a couple
good seasons you were an mvp or super
bowl cool i get it
you're basically you're not even aaron
rodgers at this point
mahomey that's not my homie my homes
like the fact that you even have the
audacity
the freaking audacity to compare
yourself with brady
have a little respect have a little like
less of an ego to say you know what he's
the goat i hope and pray
to even be in the conversation with him
one day the fact that you have the ego
to say oh we'll see in 20 years who's
better
bro if you might be lucky to win one
more super bowl
mahomey okay so dude you're nowhere near
tom brady's level if you you'd be lucky
to play until your 40s like tom brady
i i i wasn't a homestand before this but
if this is the way that he's going with
this with this ego
oh my god and they're going to be
players coming after this guy
you know how players have a target on
their back sometimes mahomey
they're coming after you you're nowhere
near goat level like tom brady
you think they're going to go after him
this season hell yeah you think i might
even get into the nfl and go after him
okay and you're you're a record-breaking
guy you're a superstar here all
county wide receiver records i might
quit the podcast to go back to the nfl
just to take ricky what do you think
about this
uh you know i'm gonna come on an
agreement no i'm a miner
i i i'm a huge tom brady fan uh
and i think he's an excellent uh and i
think that uh
you know he had 20-year career is it 20
years if not longer
yeah his 20-year career i i i hate to i
hate to say it but i agree with you adam
mahomes has not done even a quarter
he hasn't even played a quarter of the
time that brady's been playing
uh he has a lot to go to prove himself
uh to be able to make those kind of
statements but
but to play the devil's advocate he says
in 20 years
so you know he has essentially he's
putting a timeline on when he's going to
prove
that he is better but for now the time
being it's a big statement
i just don't uh i don't know man it's
just difficult paul what you think you
know something about football why don't
you say something about this because i
don't see sam i see you and that's
exactly what i was looking for for the
football debate
yeah i'm with you with i'm actually
agreeing with adam here shocker
because be humble
and you're nowhere even close again
there's a lot of quarterbacks in this
world that's won an mvp
and have won a super bowl so he's not
actually that special
in the realm of great quarterbacks i
mean terry bradshaw's got four
uh joe montana still got four i think
um you know eli manning's got two like
you're not even at eli manning's level
yet bro
right and it does have an envelope and
again he's not even near peyton manning
yet
guys you're missing the whole point here
wow you missing the whole point here
are you flipping like i thought for sure
you or you
or you one of you guys would have said
this paul hear me out
case study robert griffin can i be the
one against three here can i be the one
against three and you guys can trash me
you can call me out you can say you have
no clue what you're talking about
but hear me out my verdict okay so this
guy who's supposed to be the number one
pick comes out
and says to s-i in an interview trevor
lawrence that everybody's raving about
that this guy's gonna be
the next great whoever they're talking
about they're comparing them to who
to a manning he's gonna be the legendary
next guy
you know what he says in an si interview
here's what he says it's not like i need
this
for my life to be okay i want to do this
because i want to be the best
i can be i want to maximize my potential
who wouldn't want to you kind of waste
it if you don't right
what the hell are we talking about the
number one pick then everyone comes out
and says this guy doesn't have a chip on
his shoulder right
he doesn't have a chip on his shoulder
no chip on his shoulder okay
you just signed a 504 million dollar
contract with a guy named patma holmes
okay you give this guy 504 million
dollars right after he signs he owns the
kansas city
royals he becomes one of the owners part
on the right
and this guy has the audacity
to go up against the greatest of all
time do you realize if i'm sitting there
as an owner
just pay this guy 504 million my biggest
concern is this guy can do everything
and anything he still wants to go after
the guy
we got the right guy in our corner i
don't care whether he's right or wrong
seven championships very difficult the
records that brady had with 52-something
very difficult did you see pat mahone's
first season how many yards did he throw
in his first season
first or second season the second season
when he played if you look at this guy's
stats
if you look at his stats of what he did
in the last three seasons
it's ridiculous by the way brady doesn't
compare to
his stats in the first couple of seasons
it's not even comparing he was a game
manager when he came into the league he
didn't come into his own but
but you're talking about a guy you're
talking about a guy mahomes
who's all game he wants to compete he's
not afraid
and he's likable he's not arrogant he's
not cocky
he's not manziel he's not he's not baker
mayfield
he won a super bowl already he got an
mvp already
the guys how old is mahomes right now 25
or 26.
how old is the guy actually one on how
old this is how old is this guy what is
his age that's what i want to know how
old is mahomes he is right now
25. he's 25 years old calling out brady
at 43 years old
that he's not scared he's got 18 more
years if he plays for 43
and it kind of you know health and the
way they're doing exercises today
to be able to make players play a long
time i love
the fact that he says we're not going to
know for 20 years that's not a shot to
me
all it tells me is as a fan thank god
there's guys that still think like
mahomes who say
hey the reason why we loved kobe was
what you call michael
jordan black jesus to me that's just
mike i'm gonna go against him i love the
fact that mohammed said this
fyi you know who wins here do you know
who wins here with mahomes comments who
do you think wins here
the the the owner of the team because
he's to fight who who else you think
wins you who do you think wins here the
most
the viewers the fans yes the fans the
league they have a face that's not
afraid when kobe was not afraid to go up
against
jordan the fans won the league one the
nba today is pathetic
let's hug each other let's it's not fair
let's do this these are my boys these
are my this there is no competition let
me go play with these guys let me take
seven days off because i'm going through
challenges right now i don't need to
play this guy's saying no no no
i'm coming for you and you may be better
than me but we're going to find that
into you yeah i know you're right
i got a lot of respect for a guy like
that man and by the way
you know what are the likelihood of this
guy passing up brady you know what the
chances of that is
passing them off how as being the goat
that's being the greatest of all time
what's the likelihood
one percent next to nothing next to
nothing
next to nothing but do you want that guy
worrying
your journey yes i guarantee you would
want that guy being you because he's
willing to fight
versus the trevor lawrence i don't
really need this
i don't really need you know what you
don't need this go to fourth pick
instead of first pick and set again the
king kong contract first pick yet
i don't really need this you're saying
you want yourself i'm gonna battle you
on that one
stop it the only the only thing i'm
going to say is actions will speak loud
in the word i don't really care what
trevor lawrence says
if he's putting in the work i don't
really care what he's i tell you i
i okay i will sure it's good it's good
if he says
those things what are you talking about
because look at eli manning eli manning
was not that guy
right he looked like a doe but he's not
an eli manning eli manning is not trevor
lawrence trevor lawrence is better than
eli manning
it's not in the same league i don't even
think you want i don't know
oh you kidding me oh no i agreed of
course so you can't make the comparison
but yeah i mean still went number one
and eli manning won two championships
and he took two away from our buddy yeah
brady so
without eli manning in his life at the
end of the day i want actions over words
so if if if mahomes is talking more than
putting in the work
what are you then i don't want i don't i
don't care this is not a guy that hasn't
proven any this guy won a super bowl and
he won
mvp you're not talking about a schlep
here no but he's still 25. i that's even
more of a reason
but i want to see you at 30. like let me
just let's just get the third let's
just stop i think we need to try i don't
think we need to cover a topic before we
end the show if we have time
just go ahead because he might not be
alive by next week what's the story this
guy navalny navalny
universe navalny you want to talk about
that i think we need to because he might
not be alive by now what page are we on
that's page seven okay let's go to page
seven
ricky's already if you want if you want
to go to uh page seven of john stockton
i'm there putin warns west of harsh
response if
it crosses russia's red lines reuters
story vladimir putin warned the west on
wednesday not to cross
russia's red line says moscow would
respond swiftly and harshly to any
provocations and those responsible would
regret it at a time of acute crisis and
ties with the united states and europe
the russian troops masses
mass near ukraine and opposition leader
alexey navalny on hunger strike in jail
the kremlin leader used the state
of the nation speech to project a
message of russian strength and defiance
in the face of outside threats
putin who is 68 and has dominated russia
for two decades made no mention of
navalny
washington last week tightened sanctions
on russia over accusations of computer
hacking
and election interference and the czech
republic accused moscow of a role in
explosions
at an arms depot in 2014 both expelled
russia's diplomats russia denied
wrongdoing and responded with
tit-for-tat expulsions
i'm going to read the next part then i'm
going to give it to you here on navalny
dozens of
uh naval news supporters the rest of the
day of a protest against
vladimir putin this is a newsweek story
police in russia started making arrests
early wednesday a day
when protests in support of jailed
opposition figure alexi navalny are
expected to draw tens of thousands of
people in the streets of the country
there was an urgency to the scheduling
of the protest of navalny due to his
reported
faltering health which has generated
international concerns so
adam you look like got something to say
about this go ahead no i don't know how
much time we have left but
look this guy lexi naval is a serious
guy man okay
this is a guy who was if you ever seen
that
video of him being poisoned on an
airplane
he's dying on a plane he leaves the
country ends up in germany
uh recovers recuperates goes back
to ger back to russia he could have just
left the country and never came back
because he knew what he was in for
he said i'm going back gets jailed
he's in jail for however long he's
this guy's he's a serious dude he's got
some serious balls here
and he's going against putin i know
you're a big fan of putin i'm not
putting words in your mouth but
that you respect putin a lot i told you
that you did win
the last time i saw you when i said when
you said the beach it was no longer but
you said you respect
putin more than biden i said that yes
why did i say that i don't know you're
about to you're good about to speak but
this guy putin he's a murderer he's a
thug uh and a lot of people do respect
him because he's a
tough guy um but the world is watching
and now this guy's at a hunger strike
and um we'll see what happens here so
i got respect for this guy navalny he's
i don't know what he's doing
and then regarding um what's going on in
crimea
the analogy here with crimea is russia
cares about this
beyond it's kind of like how china cares
about taiwan
what's going on what's that go ahead
keep going i heard him go ahead you got
you've got all sorts of hearing
um anyway
this guy is legit and i don't i
this guy's about to die more than like
he's on a hunger strike he's
being jailed he's i don't know
how much longer he's got left that's my
concern where are you at
um i'm with you as far as him going and
then coming back
he obviously had a point to prove and
yeah he is on i read up on a little bit
yesterday
uh but i mean at the end of the day
here's what it comes down to
uh you know we're talking about martyrs
earlier right so what do you think
what do you think he wants to be a
martyr for novel this guy
nawali what do you think he wants to be
murdered for in your opinion like
he's wanting to be like martyr likely
the corruption and
the uh everything that's surrounding
putin
and everything that he stands for okay
so what do you think about putin them
saying that he's fine
he's perfectly fine that he's good can
you trust that whatsoever that's like
when china says
anything how can you trust them okay so
what it comes down to
is it it comes out to something very
very very very simple
it's not difficult to to look at it or
to have a different perspective on it
when poon is in a position to where he
can
expose him and say hey he's fine right
because that's what he's saying
right that's what the government's
saying if i'm mistaken that he's good
right or am i i'm a mistake
yeah i guess they're saying he's not a
hunger strike he's dying in prison
he's fine yeah if he's fine then show
him to the public
bringing money show them that he's fine
right to to discredit all because
they're trying to discredit him
right that's what they're trying to do
so he's trying to discredit food well
boone's also trying to discredit him
that's why he hasn't locked up so show
that he's fine
bring him out and show the world because
it's a world story you guys are on the
same page on this
uh to a certain extent yeah yes or no
yeah i think i'm on team navalny not i'm
not
that's what he's done no i'm not a putin
fan
i never told you that i never maybe you
were emotional
no i i've no i don't get no bro you said
you like i said let me oh by the way
let me clear that up you said that let
me clear that up this is the way i talk
there's not emotion i i come from a loud
ass mexican family
people like you talk people not be
emotional but you're emotional no no i
don't know how they speak in your house
but in my house everybody when we have
dinner speaks over each other
that's just the way it is this is the
way i talk have you met alejandro or no
i have not
like it's funny because i always even
when i do lives you're telling people
not to be emotional but you're emotional
i don't know how it is in your household
but in my household everybody yells
i'm cool with no reason don't apologize
to me bro oh
trust me i have zero plans of
apologizing to you okay now what i'm
getting at is that
just for the viewers this is the way we
talk in my house if you talk to my wife
my mom is my wife
300 bucks would you apologize no i would
never apologize to you for anything not
even 300
but what i'm getting at is i want seven
hundred dollars more in quarters ricardo
i got you don't worry about it what are
you gonna do with those quarters i'm
actually so curious what you're gonna do
with that by the way let's say
laundry day okay so let's uh uh by the
way do you have any takes on navalny and
putin and what's going on in russia
i'd say that's the part about america
where at least we have the ability to
see what the alternative option is and
then we decide okay that
in russia you don't really have that
because you don't have a lot of options
he tells you i'm going to be here for a
while you can't do nothing about it and
russians kind of say okay
that's where we're going that's the
difference between what we still have in
america
and what some other countries don't have
it's the benefit of how america was
founded on okay ky if you want to pull
up we got a video from
from our buddy tom zenner who has not
been here this week but he's got a video
for us with vt post i want to share with
you guys
vt post stories this last week was
probably
one of the most fiery weeks ever on vt
post if you haven't
yet that's my dad and i somebody sent
this to me so tom's got a message for us
here from where is he at is he had
manhattan beach rubbing it in
he's in manhattan beach paying out
additional 13.3
taxes and looking the way that he does
tom what do you got to tell us tom
what's up pat ricky adam kai how you
guys doing out in boca
nice day brewing here in california i
got you guys great podcast today
thumbs up from me all the way out here
in l.a by the way
you guys end in a few minutes i'm going
to keep a lot of these stories going at
vtpost.com let me show you a little bit
about what we're working on today
biggie smalls his estate is going to be
managed by william morris so there might
be some new content wow coming from
biggie smalls if you're a fan of his
jeff bezos isn't the only big time
executive leaving amazon
he's got dozens of senior vps that are
bailing on him right now too we've got
that score
story and how about this there's a 90
year old grandma
a granny in china that got scammed out
of 32 million bucks so we got all kinds
of stories like that
all day vtpost.com by the way adam
here's a little investing
advice for you for free from me take
some of those quarters that ricky
brought for you
from california invest in vip's premium
service
it's only a buck a month okay that's it
you get some great stuff have a great
day guys
i will see you in the studio on tuesday
it's a good investment
i'll tell you what i'll take his
investment anyone who wants postdocs
submit your name whoever's not submitted
to vtpost.com
and wants to be it's a dollar a month
you have 300
in quarters on me i will donate that
money so whoever submits their name you
can send an email to
kai maybe you can speak up i will take
these three hundred dollars in quarters
and gift it to our value chain and pay
for whoever wants to sign up
first come first serve and i'll have
seven hundred dollars more in quarters
to donate as well
well gang this has been great ricky good
to have you back thank you for having me
back
great debate great discourse this course
folks if you liked it
click on that subscribe button many of
you guys were getting the text messages
that we were sending you we've been
skipping on that last couple days so
make sure you're also clicking on the
notification button so youtube sends
these videos to you the moment we go
live haven't said that
have a great weekend everybody we'll do
it again next week take care bye bye bye
bye
you